a lot of things we couldn't say back
then because you know we had to be all
nice and PG now you get to hear like the
real stuff that happened behind the
scenes you know the story behind that I
wasn't originally for us was it for
Backstreet no who was before
[Music]
embracing a good look back at Nostalgia
because you know with the way the world
is now and the older you get you know it
gets a little depressing so it's always
nice to kind of look back and remember
those good days and just kind of feel
like a teenager again I'm not sure Lance
if I should thank you or if I should
Blame You Are you able to see those
frosted tips oh yeah you should be proud
of those things you've already had some
amazing guests on frosted tips that I
gotta ask you who is the dream boy band
member that you would love to have on
the show no one's ever asked me that
before there's so many great ones right
um I would love to get to know One
Direction a little bit because I've
never met those guys
[Music]
listen the Super Bowl is coming up and
of course Rihanna is performing you
performed at the Super Bowl in 2001 it
was probably the best weekend of my life
I am super excited for Rihanna she's oh
my God it's perfect for the Super Bowl
halftime show I wish she was coming out
with new music at the same time
she might surprise us I'm hoping but do
you think I don't know it would be a
shame if she didn't come out with
something
I love you again
I would love to see some really good
special guests because that's that's
what's fun like who is going to pop out
on the stage oh yeah and how many
seconds do they get